nos encontramos a 30 kilómetros de la
población de vilo jurídica donde está la
atención en ucrania en este momento allí
al menos 60 personas están atrapadas en
un refugio subterráneo después de que
las tropas rusas bombardearon esta
población durante la noche según nos
informan de la gobernación de la
provincia del lugar no tienen ningún
contacto con ellos se creen que hay
muchos de ellos estarían muertos pero no
hay confirmación ni de heridos ni de
muertos porque no hay comunicación con
el interior del pueblo que sigue siendo
bombardeado en estos momentos nosotros
estamos en el área y vemos como hay
bombardeos como haya hay ataques desde
artillería así que para las tropas ha
sido imposible entrar a recuperar a esas
personas como también sucede en la
población de tzipi livni acá donde hay
11 personas también atrapadas en un
refugio subterráneo con ellas se han
tenido comunicación pero no han podido
tampoco entrar a rescatarlas por la
misma situación que se encuentra en este
momento nosotros íbamos camino a la
ciudad de lis y chang pasamos por el
cruce de carretera que nos llevaba a
estas poblaciones estaba siendo
totalmente atacado constantemente
especialmente en los áreas de la
refinería que es uno de los objetivos de
las tropas rusas según las autoridades
esta refinería no está en funcionamiento
hace años pero los rusos creen que de
ahí los sorprende nos están sacando
algunas reservas de gasolina que
necesitan para sus operaciones la ciudad
del isi chang está siendo rodeada y
atacada constantemente por las tropas
rusas sin embargo al interior las tropas
ucranianas todavía tienen el control de
esta gran ciudad donde se prevee que los
heridos o también aquellos fallecidos
que logren salir de esas poblaciones
lleguen en las próximas horas si es que
los ataques en esa región cesan